hallo
herzlich willkommen zu salehs trend
heute gibt es ein leckeres zum
mittagessen und zwar startet jetzt eine
neue kategorie und die heißt was koche
ich heute denn bei uns ist auch oft so
ich stehe dann da morgens oder mittags
und denke mir okay was koche ich
eigentlich heute und manchmal muss es
gar nichts ausgefallen sein oder sehr
aufwendiges sind oftmals hat diese
mittagessen die einfach schnell
zubereitet sind die man dann einfach so
im alltag kurz zubereiten kann
heute mache ich eine onboard rezept es
ist vegetarisch mit pilzen und zucchini
und ich denke es ist ziemlich lecker und
wer einfach mal kurz die zutaten ein die
werden kein fleisch weil ich finde ich
finde wenn man pilze mit drin habt ist
sowieso wie so ein zweiter satz ich
finde es muss man immer schwächer
das wäre zu groß schien ja finde ich
schon jetzt mal die zutaten das rezept
reicht für etwa vier personen also ich
brauche zwei bis drei esslöffel olivenöl
hier habe ich nudel ich habe zahle 350
gramm 600 gramm wasser 100 gramm sahne
eine zwiebel 2 knoblauchzehen eine kurze
pini hier sind tiefgekühlte erbsen 200
gramm und 250 g champignons und später
halb europa kräuter die holen wir sind
frisch aber ich mache das alles jetzt in
einer pfanne das heißt wir müssen vor
hat nudeln jetzt nicht abkochen deswegen
auch wan port und das einzige was ich
jetzt mache ist dass ich jetzt die
zwiebeln und die knoblauchzehen fein
hacken und dann eben kurz vorher
anbraten bevor der rest mit dazu kommt
dort heißt es das heißt auf englisch
übersetzt ein auto eigentlich nichts
anderes mit eintopf erspart sich als
extrem viel geschirr und kann viel
schneller auch arbeiten hat nur einen
top und muss nicht irgendwie zwei drei
töpfe beobachten so ganz praktisch
jetzt kann ich bereits das olivenöl in
einer pfanne geben
dann müsste halt eine hohe pfanne oder
einen topf nehmen dann kommen da die
zwiebel mit rein
gemeinsam mit den club 18 und die
bratschistin investiert an und nehme
aber die hitze so ein bisschen runter
dass sie jetzt nicht anbrennen und in
der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal die
champignons vierteln und die zucchini
klein schneiden
gibt es unterschiede beim weißen
braunbär erstes noch von der farbe her
besser gefällt ich finde dass ihr
natürlicher aus und der hat weniger
wasser mit drin als weniger feuchtigkeit
schrumpft dadurch weniger und hat ein
musiker sapporo
jetzt gebe es die champignon mit in die
pfanne preisunterschied brauchen oder
wollen ja dass preis dieser beide gleich
und schneidet noch die zucchini klein
der npd will nimmt natürlich immer die
weißen schamlos
jetzt kommen die zucchinis auch mit rein
ich brate jetzt auch noch ganz kurz mit
aber auch gleich ein schönes aroma im
gericht
und jetzt geht auch schon meine pfanne
ist schon ziemlich knapp also besser ist
wirklich in einem großen topf oder in
einer höheren pfanne
aber es funktioniert
so und jetzt gebe ich noch die sport gts
mit rein
es sind ja keine spaghetti stadt wird
und ich habe einmal dass die gut rein
kosten
und für das wasser noch mit dazu
so und jetzt der deckel drauf und dann
lasse ich es erstmal aufkochen und rührt
dann gleich nochmal durch
so jetzt auch gekocht wird kann man ganz
kurz mal durchspielen
seht ihr mich über so viel und jetzt
muss ich das nochmal ab mit abgedeckten
deckel etwa 10 minuten kochen lassen ist
halt immer mal wieder umrühren damit die
tag der talent zusammenkleben und ich
kann das aber jetzt schon mal würzen mit
salz und pfeffer und später gebe ich
noch frische kräuter mit treiben
und die hitze müssen wir jetzt natürlich
reduzieren auf etwa mittlere stufe ich
habe zwischendurch immer mal wieder
berührt das steht uns etwas seit acht
neun minuten auf dem herd und die nudeln
sind noch sehr bissfest jetzt gebe ich
die sahne getrennt damit die einfach
auch noch ein bisschen mit kochen kann
und auch die erbsen sind ja noch
gefroren
gebe ich dann noch mal ganz gut deckel
drauf und kann inzwischen schon mal die
petersilie fein hacken
da habe ich jetzt einfach hinten ein
bisschen was weg gezupft und es
gerichtet auch gleich fertig das heißt
ich kann schon ein paar mal sahen holen
die teller richten und stand zeitgleich
wie ich alles der meere so ich gebe
jetzt die petersilie mit rein
ihr könnt natürlich auch andere kräuter
nehmen aber peter seele passt gut zu den
champignons ich würde noch ein bisschen
nach mit chili und dann kommt noch etwas
getrübt mit parmesan hartkäse eigentlich
kempa sahen also nach käse genau aber
ich kann den namen nicht aussprechen
ja richtig dicke damen kam sah er sich
der parmesan oregano einfach käse nennen
stückzahl italienischer moral und käse
kauft wirklich niemals niemals fertig
kasten gebracht
weg ist immer frisch darüber reiben
der schmeckt auch richtig lecker genau
da hat soll ich so nicht sowieso
kristallisiert sich die kristalle drin
der schläger war das alles aussieht
richtig fesch und es riecht auch richtig
toll also vor allem die erbsen und die
champignons und die petersilie das
riecht wirklich sehr lecker hintern und
ohne fleisch schon riesiger frauen
nudeltopf
da kommst du jetzt die erste portion ich
mag sein
nur wenn ihr nun richtig bissfesten also
nicht labbrig genau dann ist darauf
achten dass ihr die nudeln einfach nicht
zu weich kochen ist schön darauf achten
dass sie noch bissfest sind ein bisschen
auch noch mal käse darüber und der murat
muss natürlich wussten war gänge hallte
es gibt maximal eine viertelstunde
dankeschön
ich finde das wort rezepte kann man
wirklich einfach mal auf dich schneller
machen
morath lass dir jetzt viel zeit mit
warten
es ist alles sehr heiß
80 grad ich höre lange bitten
sprich zu mir ich mich super und dadurch
das rezept so schnell gemacht wird es
sind auch die champignons so richtig
bissfest genau also die zucchini sind
bisher ist die champignons und bissfest
die erstens natürlich noch richtig schön
wenn man sie nicht am anfang mit dazu
gegeben haben sondern zum schluss und
ich denke der murat sagt lecker oder
lego und alles ist perfekt genau also
ihr müsst auf jeden fall wirklich darauf
achten das ganze nicht zu verkochen denn
dann schmeckt einfach nur noch eine
pampe aber so richtig schmeckt wirklich
super und das rezept gibt's zum
nachlesen auf cds - blog.de und falls
ihr weitere ideen habt oder zum beispiel
rezepte die ich mal machen soll
dann schickt sie mir einfach ich mache
dann gerne in meiner kategorie was komme
ich heute
also viel spaß beim nachkochen und bis
zum nächsten mal noch einmal ein
bisschen putenbrust reiber wenn man mit
fleisch möchte maria jepsen weglassen
verriet rooney weglassen nicht so
wirklich gefällt mir
mit
hmm